that was awesome oh my God oh my God
that was super important to get like
that wind and to get like the right
amount of Ripple but this is something
that's kind of hard to do in simulation
already anytime there's fur and water
interacting I'm in love so it was filmed
with a green sleeve most of the time and
it was holding like his pen behind his
back classic yeah sometimes the old
tricks work best huh
thanks to vesi for sponsoring this video
stick around so you can find out how to
get 25 off of each pair of vessies hey
how's it going welcome back to another
episode of visual effects artists react
today we've got two fresh faces with us
we got Jose
did I say that right perfect she joins
us from Rodeo effects all the way from
Montreal thank you so much for joining
us I'm honored to have you here well I'm
super happy to be here as well of course
we've also got the beautiful Jordan come
on now come on now I'm blushing already
Jordan this is your first day on the VFX
couch it's surreal I gotta say I'm used
to being on the other side of the screen
so this is this is wild but very
exciting I gotta say Jose you've been a
VFX supervisor a CGI supervisor a
creature VFX supervisor before you've
actually been in the trenches animating
and simulating all kinds of muscle and
fur yeah yeah I've been like doing at
first like cfx work a lot like meaning
like all the simulations for cloth for
hair for muscle for flesh anything that
you guys know is gonna have like a
physical behavior in a way we're like
the layer on top that tries to make it
more believable and it's one of my
favorite layers 100 I'm right there with
you people tend to forget that it's like
you have a creature you animate it and
that's just the first step there's so
much that goes on to making a believable
animation and it all kind of comes down
to being able to simulate those sort of
like reactions right yeah those Jiggles
those movements those attention of the
muscles we try to bring in like that
little level of uh realism Houdini is a
program that allows for very very
complex simulations and so we're going
to be taking a look at some complex
simulations today I don't know Houdini
but you do and you're an expert and so
I'm prepared to learn a lot from the
both of you yeah I will try to teach you
okay great yes she will
so what's up what's our first clip we're
going to look at the Paddington 2.
already anytime there's fur and water
interacting I'm in love instantly and
that was a cool sequence to work on
seriously and it's like the finishing
point of the movie you know where all
the tension is there
so what we acted on mostly was like
obviously the fur and all the the code
simulation and the hair simulation you
cannot see it as much there but there's
like a hair layer on the coat and the
hat you know it kind of has like a very
long yeah yeah you can see it more like
when it's not underwater I love the way
the light is going through the further
like it's backlit just perfectly you can
really see the detail of the hair and
the fur sort of just swishing around in
this particular example we would do the
cloud simulation before and then we
would pass that on and they would
actually Collide the fur with the cloth
with the cloth yeah on top so that you
would get especially like around the
sleeve so that you can feel like the
weight of the cloth with the hair coming
out I would imagine it starts to get
pretty large and slow working with all
these different solvers combining and
the first simulation is that actually
interacting with any sort of fluid at
all or is that more just it's uh it's
not interacting well except for that
shot you know where it's coming out
there's probably like an interaction
with the fluid but the rest when it is
underwater it's more like a noise
pattern if you want like waviness that
is
yeah we had like a noise pattern
something that was making it move a
little bit and then was interacting like
with the velocity like if it was
swimming away then it would like pushes
the hair in the other direction but see
this you know it's just like current
that are in the water that are a little
bit invisible that makes it float
interesting he moves his head and like
the Hat actually flaps that's an actual
thing you have to do yeah that was fun
to do actually the Hat actually was
probably harder to nail than the the
coats what yeah because you know how
does that hat move into water you know
probably that's maybe not like 100
realistic it feels realistic enough that
I don't notice it yeah and that's the
point right but that's it you had to go
like easy enough that you get just a
little bit of movement it was
challenging but it was fun I really want
to take a look at this shot from
Zombieland too there's this whole
monster truck sequence and a bunch of
zombies and instead of double tapping
it's double revving I'm excited about
this one
oh here we go there it is I had a
monster truck wait was that a real truck
nope that's fake that's CG was there a
truck at all in this scene yeah yeah
there was a truck it had a real truck
okay yeah
oh dude
oh this is so my cup of tea this is
awesome we did like a super simple
rudimentary version of this over there
yes it's so true it's so true yeah got
very humbled in the process yeah
if you look at the crowd there's like
four guys and three girls that's all
eight models oh eight models just uh
okay yeah and we're using like a texture
variation and wow but you know they're
all like kind of like grayish and uh
beige you know oh yeah the detail is so
small you can't differentiate between
all the different models they could
literally be the same model and most
people probably wouldn't notice yeah
come on
that was awesome oh my God oh my God I
love how there's like there's a double
tap the smash there this would be so fun
to work on this is so cool and the crowd
actually that was for this time down in
Houdini which we don't do that often
because it's not quite there yet we
found it
so at first we modeled like all our
characters and then we had the cloth and
then I took those models and we did the
first passive simulation like to say
okay this coat is going to behave like
this and the pants and the hair and once
that was done the crowd Department took
those like simulation settings and
integrated them in Houdini in the crowd
solver so most of the crowds add like
Cloud simulation but that was done on
the fly with the crowd Sim then out of
that there's shots like we saw before
like when they're on the truck and
climbing or like flying in the air those
were actually an animated so there's
always a couple of zombies that will be
animated by the animation department and
then when we get those back and then
fine tune the simulation like those
running in the front they're almost like
the heroes yeah yeah that's it so we're
assimilating them like these two guys
obviously the guy that gets crushed yeah
wait that dude totally just stepped on a
piece of Fire
[Laughter]
those are the kind of scenes I could
watch a hundred times and just just
always find something new to appreciate
[Music]
delayed reveal for Dumbo he's still
covered he's still obscured well because
he's supposed to be a monster right like
a an off-putting he's so adorable yeah
he is adorable Amanda's ears
you know we didn't do the elephant right
[Laughter]
oh man these clips because there's so
many cool cfx and all I did is like the
no arm guy
so in the movie Dumbo here we have
Bullseye but he's missing an arm and
obviously he's not missing an arm in
real life so this is an arm that you
have to remove when I watch the scene
the only thing I can notice is what
would be behind his real arm there it's
all invisible effects so you don't
really notice it and it's like the
camera is moving so you don't just have
an Easy Clean Plate you have people
moving behind him as well like look at
her yeah that has to be replaced oh my
God she's blocking it paint and
compositing Magic huh respect respect oh
my goodness a lot of patience so it was
filmed with a green sleeve most of the
time and he was holding like his pen
behind his back classic yeah sometimes
the old tricks work best even when you
have your arm like behind your back like
this you still have all of this yeah now
replaced to replace and it's not just
simply a matter of okay here's the part
that you don't want and then put
something new on there usually has to be
some sort of like transition zone to
really make it work so how much of the
shoulder and what I'm imagining also
some of his chest in the side of his
body
absolutely in this one I think maybe the
bottom of the jacket to the right we
were keeping but the whole top like this
would be like completely CG okay so all
the pins there are also seen yes or did
we comp them back on top I don't
understand remember okay I can
would work because then you still have
like the transition through the clock
working nicely that's it and the pins
are kind of separate you can and they
don't move that much and this actually
was the easiest of all the the outfit he
had that was the easiest one to deal
with it's more like a solid you know has
like a jacket it has more structure to
it so it doesn't have a lot of fold but
these here we were trying it has like
those Spenders on so we were trying to
stay like to the right of the suspender
and they were kind of smart about it
like because those suspenders actually
really helped us because it's it's that
hard line where you can do all your work
but sometimes you get some folds that
are going through the suspenders see it
starts from one side and goes into the
shirt so we had to go further to have a
fold that goes from one side to the
other that's something no one would ever
until you're like how do I do this oh I
got it now I gotta do it
my biggest
another movie that you worked on is the
aeronauts these were the hot air balloon
Specialists they were and this whole
movie is about their sort of Adventures
and the horroring tales so we hear we
have Jin from Rogue one and of course
Stephen Hawking he invented black holes
so of course it's a perfect pairing on a
hot air balloon we need to lose weight
the art Direction here is fantastic oh
man yeah oh you beat me by one and a
half seconds what's interesting is that
it's not just like a hot air balloon
there's also a net around the hot air
balloon yeah don't I know it oh boy okay
[Music]
one of the challenges is that we had to
start like from partially inflated
balloon and then go down you know and
losing the inflation over time yeah I
was definitely noticing that because
when you lose that inflation you end up
with more wrinkles that's it and you
have to to modulate that oh my God I
mean look at the yeah the ripples like
undulating oh I did that
I think I'm about to tell them that was
super important to get like that women
to get like the right amount of Ripple
but this is something that's kind of
hard to do in simulation to get all
those fine details most of the plate was
like on the blue screen and all the
wires like coming out to the basket were
real and we were adding after the ring
so we would match the ring and then
attach back to it again having that hard
point then animation would take that and
give like some movement to the balloon
and then I had Maps if I believe to
simulate like air current and then I had
like a noise coming up so it was not
even simulated uh displacement yeah and
I would just like stretched it out to
get like those um yeah I'm looking at
all those little ripples there that are
catching the highlights so you see how
how circular they are because I would
stretch them in just one in One
Direction so I mean but then how are you
getting that sort of like curvy wave
going out like that well then there's a
layer of simulation as well Okay cool so
for the large scale you would do a
simulation and for that that granular
detail you would use displacement Maps I
think that helped us like to nail that
look really fast to get like the right
Behavior
so for this one it was harder in the
sense that you know it was like a
one-off from all the rest of the shots
so we had to think of a system how to do
this I asked for the modeling Department
to take the balloon and give me a final
shape and then I was able to blend shape
between the two oh blue Shades really a
great solution between the two and then
I added simulation on top of my result
gotcha so a blend shape is basically you
have a 3D model and you can deform it
into one shape and then as long as you
have the same number of polygons and
vertices you can deform it into a
different shape and just have that
transfer between the two that's it you
have your nice little slider there's so
many different forces and different
things that you couldn't possibly think
about when it comes to these simulations
being actually real so there is a lot of
artistry involved where you're trying to
get a certain aesthetic and a certain
look and sometimes doing that by hand is
the best solution you find a way to do
it in the blend shape and animating goes
by hand I'm like this is the way to go
it looks fantastic there are so many
movies that have creature work in them
and I need to see more of them leave a
comment down below with your suggestions
so in this movie Mowgli this is a jungle
book story movie directed by Andy Circus
the creature work itself is actually
fantastic and so you actually did one of
these shots here with Shere Khan Sherry
Khan yeah
well that's Benedict Cumberbatch oh yeah
yeah it's supposed to look like him I'm
used to him looking like a dragon
there's a tiger my man has range
that's cool
when you get stuck in a tree and Ben
didn't come back
[Laughter]
well that was a hero shot right there
that was the one I was talking about oh
even that like with the interaction with
the tree too oh now he's stuck in the
tree right what was the shot where
you're talking about like the Paw
hitting his face or something yeah it
was the it was the money shot that was
in slow motion and he does this like
this and it's just that little hair on
his chin and actually you can't really
oh so like no I saw his thumb kind of
like nicked his cheek yeah and also the
arm at the end and everything and every
time you would see my hair like just
snap into position and the Collision
wasn't working because we were using a
volume for the collision and you would
use sdfs to do this right and it was the
measurement of the SDF that was actually
so yeah so an SDF is a sign distance
field and basically it's a volumetric
representation of your geometry and it
measures what is inside what is outside
and what is directly on the surface so
it's cool because it if anything is
inside it knows positionally that is
inside the mesh and it should not be or
inside the Collision geometry and should
not be that's it you want to feel like
that interaction that there's no
intersection between two things that
shouldn't intersect together
if you liked what you saw and you want
to see more like it subscribe just click
that little button down below there we
love you for it dude nailed
it I think you're losing your spot on
the couch
first take Jordan I'm gonna have to do
something about this
first thing Jordan
how what's up guys I'm Jordan and I'm
just here doing my daily workout routine
here at the studio I'm here to talk to
you about my personal favorite shoe and
today's sponsor Bessie vessies are the
perfect everyday shoe for you no matter
what you're doing no matter where you
are and no matter what the weather you
can wear them everywhere you go and
you'll look good veggies are 100
waterproof and snow proof so they're
great for winter they're comfortable and
stylish and you can wear them all the
time whether you're hiking or in the gym
or going out on a hot date in the snow
the seas are made out of this crazy
material called dynamitex it's a dual
knit climate material that keeps your
feet cool in the summer and warm in the
winter it feels like it shouldn't even
be waterproof but it is it's really
important for me to have waterproof
shoes because just like everyone else I
spill water on my shoes every day and
every time I'm doing a little Crunch and
my little toe hits the hits the water
bottle and it spills all over it's mine
it's fine because besties are waterproof
it's dry my socks are dry so while I'm
working out and stuff things can tend to
get a little stinky down there but with
besties it has antibacterial insulin so
it keeps things fresh I can wear them to
the studio and no one even know that I
worked out before honestly sometimes I
get gussies and vegans confused because
fessies are vegan they're sustainably
made and they're using considerably a
lot less water than other shoes no
animals are harmed in the making zero
animals are in my shoes so if your shoes
are getting messy say yesi to Bessie and
go to bessie.com quarter crew so you can
get 25 off of each pair of vessies
that was so much fun I'm a huge fan of
simulating stuff like that ways interact
you know getting some of reality into a
shot in a way that feels natural because
it was simulated I love that and so
thank you so much thank you for coming
on the couch with us you said it
perfectly thank you well thank you so
much for having me and I got to see
California in Los Angeles that was great
so we both won yeah where can we find
more about Rodeo effects well you can
find about Romeo everywhere you know
we're on Instagram we're on Facebook we
have our website do you have any words
for anyone who might want to get into
Creature work yes come work for me it's
going to be super fun I'll give you nice
shots to do
we have a lot to talk about the next
time you come by oh I can't wait to come
back yeah that'd be great this is a lot
of fun thank you again for coming thank
you so much good too oh thanks
appreciate it
I'll take it